[Musique]
enfin nous allons reparler de nintendo
et plus particulièrement de la saga the
legend of zelda ou plutôt les djeunes
off line gueule je ne vous cache pas que
je suis à fond sur hyrule warriors en ce
moment qui est un jeu qui me défoule
bien et que j'apprécie tout
particulièrement pour en revenir au
sujet lingle est un personnage instauré
dans les rues de warriors legends sous
forme de dlc
elle est aussi présente dans la version
définitive où nous pourrons suivre un
scénario secondaire en sa compagnie la
particularité de linker et qu'elle est
l'alter ego de link au féminin et il fut
créée pour hyrule warriors un petit peu
en mode troll car les fans de la saga
était à fond dans un trip où il
s'amusait à imaginer un link ans filles
ce qui bizarrement inspira les créateurs
mais bref là n'est pas la question
attaquons la théorie linken est une
jeune fille vivant dans le royaume
d'hyrule
mais lorsqu'elle apprend que le royaume
est en danger et se précipite pour
partir laventure afin de sauver le
château et pourquoi ça car d'après elle
elle est certaine d'être la
réincarnation du héros de la légende qui
revient à chaque fois que le mal
réapparaît du moins c'est ce que sa
grand mère n'arrêtait pas de lui dire et
qui lui confier à d'ailleurs une
boussole très spécial bien évidemment
tout ceci est amené de manière ironique
car elle n'est pas le héros de la
légende c'est bel et bien link
enfin c'est ce que je veux nous faire
croire karl hinkle serait en fait une
véritable réincarnation du héros de la
légende
laissez-moi mieux vous expliquer tout
d'abord afin de rajouter de la véracité
à mes propos il faut savoir qui relie
warriors est un spin off et non un zelda
officiel il ne fait donc pas partie de
la timeline
si vous voulez que je fasse une vidéo
sur la timeline zelda dites le moi en
commentaire mais
aonuma le créateur de breath of the wild
et un réel piliers de la saga aime
énormément le personnage de linkers et
souhaite la réutiliser pour le futur des
jeux zelda donc le personnage est entre
guillemets officielle et ne possède pas
encore de réel background est justement
j'en ai à vous proposer
dans la théorie line qu'elle serait la
descendante du link de spirit tracks et
donc de la timeline de l'adulte pour
vous résumer la chose dans cette
timeline nous sommes dans la partie du
présent d'ocarina of time la réalité qui
a continué à perdurer bien que ligne
soit remonter dans le passé afin de
dénoncer galenter pour sa trahison
sauf que du coup dans cette réalité link
n'est plus puisqu'il est retourné dans
le passé donc ganondorf en profita suite
à sa libération pour semer la pagaille
les ds sont alors pris une décision
radicale
nous nous voyez le monde rien que ça
scellant le royaume d'hyrule ganondorf
et la plupart des habitants du monde
solo et du coup nous arrivons à wind
waker puis phantom hourglass et enfin
spirit tracks avec une zelda petite
fille de tetra et la timeline s'arrête
brutalement ici avec le ring de spirit
tracks en compagnie de zelda
suite à leur victoire contre malades us
et du coup pourquoi je pense que l'hymne
quelle pourrait être la descendante de
ces deux personnages et bien c'est tout
simple la boussole de linkers link elle
est nommée par sa grand mère comme une
réincarnation du héros qui lui donne à
cette boussole et bizarrement dans
spirit tracks le héros de ce jeu possède
la boussole de la lumière lui permettant
de le mener aux ténèbres et donc au
train fantôme
cette boussole semble être réellement
l'artefact que possède lingle légué par
sa grand-mère qui pourrait être pourquoi
pas la zelda de spirit tracks ou une
descendante plus lointaines c'est très
ressemblant fortement à link pourrait
accentuer cette descendance entre
l'union de la princesse et du héros
ensuite en ce qui concerne la boussole
elle mène aux ténèbres et bizarrement
linken qui essayent tant bien que mal
d'atteindre le château d'hyrule unis
toujours nos un conflit rempli de
monstres
la boussole elle mène à ou déjà bref
mais ce qui permet de vraiment
d'affirmer ceci et que breath of the
wild semble être le regroupement des
trois timeline est que justement aonuma
qui travaille déjà sur le prochain zelda
souhaite réellement intégré winkle dans
ses prochains jeux
winkel pourrait être le symbole finale
de la timeline de l'adulte dans le futur
de la saga et serait un background
énorme pour cette dernière qui serait au
final un véritable et lui un véritable
héros de la légende
je suis trop content d'avoir pu vous
faire une petite théorie sur zelda
j'adore tellement cette saga n'hésitez
pas à laisser un petit pouce bleus et à
partager la vidéo j'ai d'ailleurs
récemment ouvert un outil pour ceux qui
souhaiteraient soutenir la chaîne
gratuitement sans débourser un seul
centime mais un petit peu de votre temps
le lien est en descriptions merci de
tout coeur à ce qu'ils feront
suivez moi sur twitter puis abonnez-vous
7 et ergo rock et que le line up soit
avec vous
[Musique]